اتواجد الان في احد المناطق السكنيه شرق
العاصمه كيف هذه المنطقه التي تعرضت صباح
اليوم لقصف صاروخيه الروسي وفقا للسلطات
المحليه الاوكرانيه كما تشاهدون عمال
الدفاع المدني يعملون في هذه الاثناء على
ازاله الانقاذ الدمار في كل مكان ويستطيع
الزمن المصور ان يقرب لكم هذه الحفره وهي
نتيجه لمخلفات الصاروخ الذي سقط وفقا
للعاملين هنا والدمار طال اجزاء واسعه من
المكان هذا المنزل دمر بالكامل والاضرار
ايضا طالت المنزل
المجاور وهنالك ايضا مركبات
حرقت بها الكامل نتيجه القصف الذي جرى
السلطات الاوكرانيه تحدثت وتحديدا هيئه
الاركان الاوكرانيه اشارت الى ان همم قصفا
صاروخيا واسعا شمله العاصمه كيافو عديده
المقاطعه والحديث عن اسقاط الدفاعات
الجويه اكثر من
سينا صاروخا من اصل اا 69 صاروخا استهدفت
الاكياب والمقاطعات تحديدا جنوب البلاد
والطاقه الاوكرانيه وزاره الطاقه
الاوكرانيه تحدثت ايضا خلال الساعه
الاخيره عن ان القصب طال بشكل مكثف البنيه
التحتيه فيكيا وفي مقاطعه اوديسامه ادى
الى انقطاعات هائله في الكهرباء هنا في
كيا باكثر من 40% وفقا لالسلطات
الاوكرانيه من السكان بلا كهرباء والوضع
يزدادوا سوءا في اوديسا التي همم قطعت
عنها الكهرباء بشكل كامل وفي لذيذ غرب
البلاد قطعت الكهرباء عن 90% من السكان
وفقا ليا السلطات الاوكرانيه الجزيره كيا